d'accueillir notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir lorenzo fumagalli bonsoir
alors lorenzo
votre témoignage met en lumière l'un des
derniers grands tabous de notre société
la sexualité des handicapés est question
corollaire faut-il créer en france un
statut d'assistant sexuel pour les
handicapés comme c'est le cas en
allemagne aux pays bas au danemark en
suisse vous êtes suisse oui vous vivez à
zurich vous êtes donc ostéopathe est
également assistant sexuel ça madame
bachelot s'oppose à ce que ça soit créée
en france vous nous raconterez votre
histoire à 20 heures
[Musique]
lorenzo re bonsoir vous avez 49 ans vous
êtes marié père de deux garçons de 20 et
22 ans vous êtes ostéopathe dans la
banlieue de zurich
et depuis quelques années vous êtes
également assistant sexuel
comment et pourquoi
un père de famille passionnée de jazz a
décidé de devenir un jour assistants
sexuels
quel impact cette activité a eu sur vos
proches et surtout en quoi consiste
l'assistance sexuelle nous allons tenter
de répondre à ces questions vous êtes né
le 20 mai 1961 dans le sud de la suisse
première année à milan c'est cela votre
père travaille pour la swissair
ensuite il est muté à bangkok quand vous
avez deux ans vous y est resté six ans
et donc des huit ans quand vous revenez
en suisse à lugano
l'école ne vous passionne pas seule la
musique vous intéresse et malgré la
pression de vos parents vous entré à
vingt ans au conservatoire de jazz de
berne alors en 1981 vous rencontrer
carine que vous épouserais et qui
deviendra la mère de vos deux enfants là
vous faites un petit boulot à l'aéroport
de zurich vous vous cherchez à cette
époque là et un jour vous listez vos
ambitions sur une feuille de papier vous
mettez un ébéniste deux pilotes de ligne
3 ostéopathe et vous serez bellis
pendant 16 ans oui un grand bonheur j'ai
pu à travailler
dans une ferme qu'on a qu'on a jetée et
le grand bonheur c'était celui de
pouvoir combiner le travail avec
l'éducation des enfants jusqu'au jour où
vos enfants ont rendez vous avec une
conseillère d'orientation et là votre
femme karine et vous en profiter pour
faire une sorte de bilan de compétences
vous posez la question de votre devenir
on vous dit
vous manquez de contacts humains mehdi
ben entre entre les choses que je
pourrais faire cette ce serait une
activité comme ma soeur ostéopathe c'est
incroyable c'est incroyable parce que là
je me suis dit bah j'avais une fois déjà
c'était le troisième un 3e ligne césar
de votre papier là vous allez prendre
quatre ans de cours et ouvrir un cabinet
d'ostéopathie voilà et un jour en lisant
le journal vous tombez sur un article où
il est question de la sexualité des
handicapés
une association qui s'appelle pro
infirmis qui est spécialisé là dedans et
qui lance un programme de formation
d'assistant sexuel et là vous vous
rendez compte que vous avez un ami
handicapé qui s'appelle hans un ébéniste
et vous n'avez jamais pensé à cette
sexualité jusqu'à ce jour là finalement
renoncé
je peux peut-être même gêné de ça mais
c'est la réalité alors le soir votre
femme vous tend un article et elle vous
dit tiens lis ça ça serait bien pour toi
et c'est le même article ouais ça c'est
dit emotionnellement c'était très fort
parce que je me suis rendu compte de la
valeur de
deux carrés qui me donnait la
possibilité de faire quelque chose dont
je me sentais
très très
capable enfin alors karine le soutien
vos enfants l'accepterons assez
facilement même si pour le plus petit
c'est un peu plus compliqué c'est ça oui
il faut qu'un jour quelqu'un qui liste
que fait-on père c'est formidable pour
qu'ils acceptent réellement en fait
c'est ça il avait un peu en quoi oui oui
oui bien sûr mais maintenant on en parle
très ouvertement
alors ce programme il ya 300 candidats
il y en a dix qui sont retenus dont vous
voilà et alors là commence la formation
c'est à dire que d'abord il faut faire
le point sur votre propre sexualité
c'est cette pas pensable de de pouvoir
faire de l'assistance d'aider quelqu'un
dans sa sexualité
si on n'a pas réfléchi sur la propre
vie sexuelle c'est vraiment une
biographie sexuel qu'on a qu'on a fait
ensuite il ya les études des différents
types de handicap
oui il y en a beaucoup c'est ça c'est
impossible de tout les étudier ces même
pas à la fin important de connaître tous
les mécaniques des handicaps c'est
finalement en 2004 que vous obtenez
votre diplôme d'assistant sexuel voilà
la première assistance que vous faites
c'est avec une italienne atteinte
d'amyotrophie
vous avez rendez vous avec elle dans un
hôtel c'est ça oui vous aviez le trac en
y allant ben oui bien sûr quand même la
première fois pour moi une expérience
en fait même gigantesque c'est vraiment
le moment pratique alors vous lui faites
quoi vous lui fait des caresses érotique
quoi c'est ça oui bon moi je fais ce que
le client là client désire oui mais ça
c'est très important je fais je fais pas
plus et si j'ai si j'arrive à
gérer les voeux des clients alors
c'est sa part oui oui là ça s'est bien
passé donc caresse érotique sur le dos
les saints l'entrejambes elle était
contente oui absolument oui prix 150
euros j'ai aussi un tarif social si à
noël des personnes
qui n'ont pas des moyens c
dans le monde des handicapés il ya des
riches et des moins riches comme partout
nation alors c'est un art très spéciale
parce que vous dites parfois il faut un
quart d'heure pour enlever un pantalon
en quoi c'est des gens qui sont
handicapés mais il n'y a aucune
aucune gêne 6 il faut du temps pour
ne serait ce que pour ceux des aliments
lorsque vous faites c'est des caresses
superficiel il n'y a pas de pénétration
n'y a pas de sexe oral c'est ça les
limites que vous avez dit c'est ce que
moi j'ai posé ouais mais chacun fait
comme il veut c'est le plus important
évidemment cc l'inventivité et
l'empathie et le coeur qu'on y met
finalement oui une chose quand et qu'il
faut pas oublier c'est la capacité de
d'ecoute même si quelqu'un ne peut pas
parler est une chose très importante
c'est de avant tout assistants sexuels
en
mai en clair le fait de dire non alors
il ya aussi une dimension humoristique
vous dites parfois on se retrouve dans
des positions absurde et on éclate de
rire voilà c'est ça que j'aime parce que
en fait la sexualité c'est la vie c'est
le bien-être c'est le soulagement il ya
vraiment parfois des situations très
drôle aussi
et je noter que les les personnes
handicapées aime aussi rire de leur
propre handicap alors au fil des
expériences vous découvrez différents
types de personnes insisté il ya un
homme avec qui vous êtes obligé dans le
vente et un alphabet pour pour
communiquer il est mentalement à
très handicapée même on a on a pu
ajouter quelques
lettrés valait un alphabet personnel
entre entre nous deux donc c'est ça qui
qui qui fait de l'assistance sexuelle
une activité
très complexe alors il et d'histoire
très émouvante évidemment vous raconter
l'histoire d'une dame qui peser 20 kg 20
minutes pour la placer sur le lit sans
lui faire mal sont évidemment parce que
très fragile ensuite elle vous demande
des caresses et et elle a sorti elle se
met à pleurer elle vous dit j'ai dû
attendre quarante ans pour pouvoir
goûter à ça c'est extraordinaire un des
moments les plus émouvants que j'ai fait
pour moi c'était vraiment dur après de
reprendre les récompenses ans est
extrêmement référencés ouais alors vous
vous occupez surtout des femmes si vous
êtes et théorie sexuelle donc c'est que
j'ai je parlais à vendin cas masculin
c'est le cas où il
il avait des problèmes avec sa sexualité
que j'ai pu l'aider qu ils se masturbent
ce soit même et
c'était une apothéloz la première fois
qu'il a pu faire ça c'était vraiment
c'était comme s'il avait découvert sa
masculinité les résultats sont probants
sont positifs vous apprenez aux
handicapés à aimer leur corps et surtout
ça supprime souvent l'agressivité oui on
veut pas vivre notre sexualité en soins
devient frustré on devient
rigide et c'est là qu'il ya des
violences extrêmes qui peuvent surgir
des assistants sexuels peuvent vraiment
à donner des soulagements il ya aussi un
grand avantage c'est que ça supprime
l'inceste parce que souvent les mamans
soit le hms astute leurs enfants
handicapés soient elles le font pas ce
qui est terrible pour l'enfant on sait
qu'il ya beaucoup de parents surtout les
mamans qui est tiède dans la sexualité
de leurs enfants et des adultes bien sûr
ce qui ce qui a
eu lieu de résoudre un problème en pause
un autre alors voilà aujourd'hui vous
faites ça 30 à 40 fois par an un oui à
peu près en dehors de votre boulot dodo
jeté aux pattes
alors en france donc roselyne bachelot
est opposé à ça on va l'écouter derrière
j'entends la misère de certaines
personnes vous avez peut-être un fils ou
une fille à petit fils une petite fille
est-ce que vous lui conseilleriez ce
métier d'assistant sexuel pourquoi pas
je sais par voisins demandant aux
auditeurs d'europe 1 s'il conseillerait
cela leur fils ou leur fille ce à quoi
vous répondez
si le fils ou la fille de madame
bachelot était handicapée elle aurait
sans doute une ou deux positions il faut
qu'on se rend compte il faut il faut
rien pour que nous on est dans cette
situation donc après c'est à nous deux
de voir qu'est ce qu'on fait avec notre
sexualité que tout à coup et est tombé
en panne mais en panne gigantesque au
madame bachelot c'est pas le sujet on ne
prend pas lorsqu'on a des
responsabilités politiques on ne prend
pas des décisions par rapport à son fils
ou sa fille qui seraient dans cette
situation là c'est absolument
désespérant d'entendre des responsables
de politiques raisonner comme ça est-ce
que c'est toujours les mêmes clients la
plupart des failles oui oui parce
qu'étant donné que moi je assistent des
femmes
les femmes aiment bien qu' il y ait une
continuité et ça crée un lien
ça peut créer un lien c'est clair c'est
un
discours très très important a peut être
un lien amoureux
qui peut être amoureux est unilatéral
c'est ça c'est pas en danger je sais un
danger c'est un discours à apprendre sur
sérieux il faut en parler moi je suis
une aide sexuelle peut-être même à
bon quand un mais je suis pas le
partenaire je sais pas bien sûr quelque
chose qui me gène seulement monsieur a
donc il l'a dit tout à l'heure avec l
ined c'était un bad qui est sûrement
prospère est-ce que sa démarche ne
pourrait pas être plus humanitaire est
ce que cette vocation ne serait pas plus
admirable si elles s'exerçaient sans
argent c'est dangereux dans l'autre sens
parce que le
danger
qu'après s'il n'y avait pas d'argent
oui c'est à dire que c'est l'argent qui
est une barrière contre la perversité
non pas contre la tartine ex contre
l'amour oui comme la psychanalyse oui
oui c'est correct pour ce à dire que
vous appelez vos aux patientes des
clients oui justement parce qu'il ya de
l'argent entre en ligne c'est ça et
comment ça se passe avec karine s'est
absolument pas là l'activité de
l'assistance sexuelle qui est reposante
repose dans notre vie sexuelle il faut
quelqu'un pour ce faire
merci à tous et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de l'inaptitude abonnez vous
mettez un pouce bleus